[Musique]
હ
autour du monde des hommes ont des
bateaux comme
maison un mode de vie antique unique et
de plus en plus
rare ce sont des peuples nomades de
l'eau en
Thaïlande vit avec ses proches sur un
kabang une traditionnelle au mode de
fabrication inchangé depuis des milliers
[Musique]
d'années au Cambodge mot et sa famille
naviguent sur leur pirogu où ils
travaillent cuisinent dorment S et
prie des histoires de Nomad
de voyage et de
[Musique]
bateaux à la frontière du Myanmar
exbmanie et de la Thaïlande la mer
d'Andaman et depuis plus de 4000 ans le
territoire des Moken
[Musique]
originaire du sud de la Chine ces hommes
ont migré vers l'archipel des
merg plus de 800 îles disséminé sur 400
km où ils peuvent pêcher et se
déplacer un vrai paradis sur terre pour
cette tribu des
mers la mer c'est pour nous c'est notre
maison c'est grâce à elle qu'on se
procure
[Musique]
c'est notre
liberté est un père de famille de 37
ans ce matin il fabrique une lance qui
sert à harpon les poissons une méthode
de pêche traditionnelle pour S dont le
nom signifie immerg dans la
mer
[Musique]
chez les Moken on apprend à nager et à
plonger dès le plus jeune
âge ces hommes poissons sont des
plongeurs émérites ils nagent en apnée
de longues minutes et ils sont réputés
pour leur vision sous-marine
exceptionnelle
il voit clair sous l'eau et repère de
loin la plus petite
[Musique]
créature quotidiennement Engy entretient
sa maison son
kabang j'arrose le bateau pour que le
bois reste
humide je m'attends à ce que le vent se
lève bientôt pour qu'il assèche le bois
il devient alors moins perméable à l'eau
je veux éviter que de l'eau s'infiltre
dans la
pirogue
entretenir le cabang c'est comme prendre
soin des membres de sa
famille je le fais pour eux pour qu'il s
sent bien et en
[Musique]
sécurité chez les moenes on navigue en
famille sur le cabang de ils sont 7 sa
femme son dernier né d'à peine 52 jours
une vieille tante et même trois enfants
qui ne sont pas les
siens les moqu considèrent qu'il est de
leur devoir de s'occuper de tous les
enfants de la
tribu le père de la grande fille et du
garçon qui sont frère et sœur
est mort d'une forte fièvre pendant la
saison des
pluies la mère est décédée un an plus
tard de la même
chose ils n pas le temps ni les moyens
d'aller voir un
médecin je suis très heureux de vivre
sur le cabang parce que je peux sauter
dans la mer m'y baigner quand je veux et
dormir sur le
bateau c'est vraiment très
amusant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on ne se sent pas à l'étroit du tout
plus il y a de monde plus on se sent
[Musique]
fort le cabang est construit à partir
d'un seul Tron d'arbre et sans aucun
clou sans qui l'embarcation est légère
et facilement
[Musique]
maneuvrable une petite merveille qui
peut naviguer en haute mer ou en eau peu
profonde
selon les men le kabang est quasiment
[Musique]
insubmersible ce bateau est différent
des autres pirogues à l'avant et à
l'arrière il y a cette échancrure si
distinctive
n permet de monter à bord du bateau
lorsquon est dans l'eau c'est très
facile de grimper à bord du cabang même
lorsquon est en ha
mer
[Musique]
dans l'après-midi le vent se
lève en profite pour Risser la voile
traditionnelle en feuille de pendalus H
son frère rapporte quelques poissons
pêchés au
[Musique]
harpon
c'est bientôt la fin de la
journée et sa famille profitent du vent
pour mettre le cap sur une autre île de
l'archipel à quelques kilomètres de
[Musique]
là
à plusieurs centaines de kilomètres de
la Thaïlande au Cambodge une autre
communauté de Nomad les Cham passent
leur vie sur le fleuve Mekong à bord de
leur
Pirog
[Musique]
notre pirogue est aussi importante que
notre vie on survit grâce à
[Musique]
elle
en cette saison il n'y a pas beaucoup de
poisson ce qu'on pêche n permet juste de
manger pour une journée et une nuit de
pêche on gagne entre 40000 ou 50000
Riel la haute saison démar que dans 2
mois
je relève le filet au bout de 30 minutes
il y a de tout parfois on trouve des
poplit ou des poissons chat on verra ce
qu'on va trouver dans le filet tout à
[Musique]
l' la famille toujours vécu d'une
pirogue en ce moment il navigue dans la
région de Kampong
Cham à la recherche des meilleures zones
de pêche ces nomades du fleuve
parcourent des centaines de kilomètres
par
[Musique]
an
aujourd'hui ils sont quatre à bord de la
pirogue mot et sa femme
saroche solè le fils de 25 ans et
mokmina la petite dernière de 6 ans les
deux filles aîné sont partis travailler
dans une usine de la
capitale de nombreux jeunes cherchent un
emploi à terre pour eux la vie sur l'eau
est trop dure trop dangereuse le fleuve
qui nourrit les hommes peut aussi tout
leur prendre
on avait aussi deux autres filles elles
sont mortes il y a
longtemps cétait les les de plus jeunes
sont
es ét petit et se sont noyé la première
est tombé de la pirogue pendant que
j'étais en train de réparer les filets
je n'avais rien entendu pour la deè une
jeune fille l' mise au bord de l'eau
sans la surveiller et la petite est
tombée on a mis du temps pour la
retrouver mais c'était trop tard
le fuveir des Cham ne se distingue pas
des autres bateaux de
pêche ce matin les h n'ont capturé qu'un
seul
poisson cette petite prise qui n'a pas
de valeur marchande sera parfaite pour
le
[Musique]
déjeuner
la plupart du temps on mange du poisson
si on a assez d'argent et que l'on est
proche du marché on peut acheter des
légumes mais le plus souvent c'est du
poisson avec de la sauce de
poisson
donc la
vaisselle je la mets là-bas derrière le
bac
rose et les vêtements je les range
là
tout ce qui estc on le S dans
la et pour tout le reste c'est ici et là
sur la
pirogue le mkong est un des plus long
fleuve du monde sur l'eau et sur les
berges la vie se déploie
[Musique]
but de notre union on attendait la nuit
pour faire nos
besoins on était
timide maintenant elle se mets à
l'arrière de la pirogue je tourne la
tête vers l'avant et ça
va dérange plus
[Musique]
ouais bien que ce soit dur on est très
uni on s'aime j'aime ma femme mes
enfants et les enfants nous
[Musique]
aiment
de retour chez les Moken en Thaïland
Engy et sa famille arrivent à
destination de l'île de
ping c'est un bon coin pour les
coquillages chez les Moken la cueillette
décrustacé est une affaire de
femme dès l'enfance maniao a appris à
cuisiner ses fruits de
mer on les fait bouillir plus ou moins
longtemps on peut aussi les manger cru
comme ça et les mélanger à d'autres
[Musique]
aliments
les men se déplacent en flottille ainsi
plusieurs embarcations naviguent de
concert c'est agréable et plus sûr et on
peut compter sur la solidarité du
groupe
on ne donne pas vraiment de leçons de
navigation les garçons viennent avec moi
ils m'observent et ils apprennent tout
simplement par
eux-mêmes cet après-midi
s compagnons ont une mission essentielle
à la survie de leur tribu trouver de
l'eau
potable connait chacune des précieuses
sources de
l'archipel je connais tous les endroits
d'approvisionnement en e potable de la
région
c'est mon père qui me les a
montré quand j'étais jeune il m'em
partout et c'est comme ça que j'ai connu
tous les sites d'E
[Musique]
frche
le cabang est tout simplement une maison
sur les flots entouré d'un véritable
terrain de
[Musique]
jeu
en fin de journée le groupe lève l'encre
à nouveau à la recherche d'un lieu plus
calme pour passer la nuit cap sur la
baie de
[Musique]
Payam
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce soir c'est boun la vieille tante qui
prépare le repas au menu poisson et
coquillage je cuisine les moules et les
fruits de mer qu'on a récolté parfois on
y ajoute quelques
épic
[Musique]
mais la mer n'est plus aussi généreuse
que dans ma
jeunesse parfois on a même de la
difficulté à trouver du poisson
oui on mange beaucoup de
poisson dans la baie de PAAm les
moquenes ne sont pas seuls d'autres
bateaux de pêche entourent leur
flottilles ces bateaux pratiquent une
pêche intensive à l'origine de la
disparition des ressources il pille le
jardin des mokenes et menace le mode de
vie et l'existence même de ces nomades
qui vivent en symbiose avec la mer
sacrée qui les
[Musique]
nourrit
la famille s'endort doucement bercée par
la mer avec laquelle elle entretient une
relation
[Musique]
spirituelle
retour au
Cambodge ce matin la famille you à la
pêche
saaroche profite du trajet pour ravuder
leur précieux
filet
je répare le filet au fur et à mesure
qu'il
s'abîme si on ne le fait pas
régulièrement on pourra pas bien
l'utiliser pour jeter son filet dans le
fleu il faut une autorisation comme les
autres
pêcheurs a d payer une redevance qui
sert à embaucher les équipe nettoie le
fleu DEES branch
trit à chaque saison on détermine le
prix à
payer si la société chargée de
l'entretien du fleuve dépense 2 millions
de Riel elle divise la somme par le
nombre de pyogues dans le village et on
paye 100000 Riel ou plus s'il le
faut après des heures de travail ardu et
sous un soleil de plomb la famille you
pêche enfin un poisson qu'elle pourra
revendre demain matin au
marché
[Musique]
c'est une bonne prise un beau poisson
comme ça on va pouvoir le
vendre non seulement ça va couvrir les
frais d'essence de la
journée mais il restera de l'argent pour
autre
chose ce poisson coûte au moins 50000
Riel aujourd'hui on a consommé 3 L
d'essence qui valent 10000 Riel avec le
reste on va acheter du riz et en donner
à la petite pour
[Musique]
l'école de retour à terre saroche rend
visite à sa niè mère de trois enfants et
nomade du méong comme
elle
je voudrais vous montrer comment on
protège les enfants pour éviter qu'il ne
tombe à l'eau comme les miens c'est
important mon fils a un an et demi on a
installé ce filet parce qu'on a peur
qu'il tombe dans l'eau parfois on
attache son pied quand on dort j'ai peur
qu'il tombe dans le fleuve comme ce de
ma
tente je me sers de ce fil pour attacher
le pied du petit au toit de la pirogue
quand il est très occupé à jouer il
oublie le fil parfois il pleure pour
qu'on l'enlève car ça l'empêche de se
déplacer mot et sa roche pêche près du
village de Kong Cham là où est enterré
une de leurs
[Musique]
filles
je reste ici car dans ma religion les
femmes n'ont pas le droit d'entrer dans
le
cimetière je suis triste ma fille me
manque à chaque fois que je viens ici
renir mes
larmes qu je pense à elle je m'assois là
et je
[Musique]
pleure mais lesam ne restent pas
longtemps assis à pleurer un mot les
caractérise la
résilience sous le régime sanguinaire
DEP une grande partie de cette minorité
musule a été exterminé par les roues
malgré tout ce peuple trouve la force de
continuer d'avancer travailler et
[Musique]
sourire
le jour se lève sur la mer
d'Andaman une fois par
an le père accompl rituel il demande à
ses ancêtres de protéger sonang et sa
[Musique]
famille
chez les M le bateau aussi est un être
vivant dont il faut prendre
soin on prépare plusieurs
offrandes de la nourriture des
gâteaux de la
liqueur de la poudre odorante pour
attirer les esprits
féminins
ce sont eux qui nous protègent des
tempêtes et qui s'assurent que la mer
sera généreuse avec
[Musique]
nous
Engy et sa famille naviguent vers la
baie de kukao un endroit symbolique qui
rappelle à tous l'incroyable puissance
de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'océan
[Musique]
NH en 2004 lorsque le tsunami le plus
meurtrier de tous les temps a frappé la
côte thaïlandaise Engy se trouvait ici
sur le parcours de cette vague
gigantesque mais sa connaissance de la
mer l'a
[Musique]
sauvé il y a une histoire qui nous est
racontée par nos aînés de génération en
génération et que tous les mquaines
connaissent c'est le récit du laboun une
énorme vague comme on a jamais vu et qui
arrache tout sur son
passage les signes avantcoureur sont le
calme inabituel de la mer l'apparition à
la surface des poissons qui vivent dans
les profondeurs et la fuite des crabes
de la plage si on remarque de tels
bouleversement il n'y a qu'une seule
consigne fuir sur une haute montagne et
c'est ce que nous avons
fait la famille de Engy et tous les
Moken ont survécu mais la plupart des
bateaux ont été
détruits les moquenes sontatri ils n'
pas de papier ils ne sont citoyens
d'aucun pays et depuis des
millénaires leur seule patrie c'est la
[Musique]
mer d'ici on peut voir la
Birmanie la frontière est à peu près à 2
he de
navigation
la seule façon de
m'identifier c'est avec mon
bateau en ce qui me concerne c'est tout
ce qu'on sait de moi quand on voit mon
kabang on sait que je suis
m le peuple men sonne la mer d'Andaman
des deux côtés de la
frontière au Myanmar et en
Thaïlande les nomades de l'eau sont
libres de circuler dans l'immensité de
[Musique]
l'océan au Cambodge la famille you met
le pied sur la terre
ferme ce matin sa roche se rend au
marché pour y vendre sa belle prise de
la
[Musique]
veille
je suis contente j'en ai tiré 80000
Riel avec cet argent je vais acheter du
riz et de l'essence pour la
pirogue j'ai acheté pour000 R de
concombre pastèque et un demi kil de
Patat
[Musique]
douces j'aimerais bien acheter des
bonnes choses comme de la viande et des
vêtements mais je n'ai pas le budget
pour ça j'attends quand j'en aurai plus
la viande de bœuf coûte très cher j'en
achète que lorsquon a beaucoup d'argent
on mange plutôt les poissons qu'on a
pêché j'aimerais bien attraper encore
des poissons comme
celui-là
motivé confiant et certain que le fleuve
sera à nouveau généreux la famille
repart
pêcher
mais le vent se lève brusquement une
tempête est peut-être à prévoir sur le
Mekong elles sont aussi soudaine que
redoutable on a rencontré cette
situation plusieurs fois pour éviter que
la pirogue ne coule je sautais dans
l'eau lors d'une tempête les vagues
étaient très grosses et comme notre
pirogue était toute petite elle a coulé
près de la berge j'avais tellement peur
que je serrais mes enfants contre moi et
je
pleurais
n il est 15h la famille délaisse son
filet de pêche et se prépare pour la
prière avant de faire la
prièreè ce qui est impur donc tout ce
qui est impropre c'est pour ça que
j'enlève mes habits et que je mets des
vêtements
blancs dans ma religion la prière est
accompagnée de gestes d'inclination de
génuflexion de
prosternation et durant la prière on
répète ces mouvements quatre
fois si par exemple le ciel devient noir
et qu'il commence à y avoir beaucoup de
vent et qu'on est qu'au deuxième
mouvement de la prière on doit continuer
les deux autres on ne doit pas
interrompre la prière et c'est seulement
une fois qu'on a terminé la prière qu'on
peut se sauver on dit que si on
interromp la prière cela constitue un
péché
soles travaille parfois avec ses parents
mais comme de nombreux jeunes Cham il ne
veut plus de cette vie dangereuse et
difficile de pêcheur
nomade je ne veux plus vivre sur la
pirogue et j'aimerais sortir mes parents
de cette ville
quand j'aurai les moyens plus tard
j'emmènerai mes parents vivre sur la
terre ferme je ne veux plus qu'il viv ce
quotidien difficile c'est la raison pour
laquelle je travaille dans une
menuiserie j'espère qu'un jour j'aurai
une affaire à moi si je réussis mes
parents pourrai avoir une vie
[Musique]
meilleure la petite dernière va à
l'école sur la terre ferme
et bientôt il n'y aura plus que mot et
sa roche à bord de la
[Musique]
pirogue
sur la mer d'Andaman nous retrouvons
Engy et sa famille son kabang est le
tout dernier exemplaire de la pirogue
traditionnelle des
Moken la quasi totalité de leur bateau
ayant disparu lors du tsunami de
2004 ils ne peuvent en construire de
nouveau en effet les lois
environnementale thaïlandaise
interdisent désormais de couper le bois
rare nécessaire à leur fabrication
si le père de famille perd sa maison sur
les flots c'est 4000 ans d'histoire
humaine qui couleront avec
[Musique]
elle notre culture est de tradition
orale on n' pas d'écrit donc la façon de
construire le cabang traditionnel va se
[Musique]
perdre auparavant les jeunes apprenaient
les techniques de construction navale en
les pratiquant
mais on n construit
plus alors désormais comment se savoir
va-t-il se
transmettre la plupart des Menes qui
n'ont pas reconstruit de cabang
utilisent des bateaux très courants en
Thaïlande les bateaux à longue
[Musique]
queue
d'autres familles de Moken qui ont perdu
leur bateau se retrouve sur l'île de
kopayam la majorité des nomades des m
est aujourd'hui sédentarisé dans des
villages de ce type et certains vivent
dans une pauvreté
extrême depuis toujours les men vivent
sur terre quelques semaines par an
durant la mousson du sud-ouest quand la
mer est agitée et
imprévisible les nomades ont pris
l'habitude de s'installer dans des hutes
temporaires aujourd'hui ces abris
temporaires sont parfois devenus leur
résidence
principale c'est très difficile de vivre
dans ce village parce que le niveau de
la mer monte sans
cesse les mques ne peuvent aller vivre
ailleurs maintenant toutes les îles
appartiennent à des sociétés
privées notre peuple qui se déplaçait
d'une île à l'autre auparavant est
désormais confiné dans des endroits
assez
hostiles aujourd'hui la famille Dey va
rendre visite au de Fillé qui font leurs
études à namken au nord de
kaolac
[Musique]
les filles de ne veulent plus vivre en
mer et s'éloignent du mode de vie
traditionnel des
m d'ailleurs s'adressent à leur père en
taille et ne pratique plus la langue
moquaine
[Musique]
je leur parle en taille parce que nous
sommes sur la terre ferme et ici la
langue d'usage c'est le
taille je ne suis pas allé à l'école
mais je suis contente que mes filles
puissent aller quand j'ai des ennuis de
santé mes filles peuvent m'aider car je
ne parle pas ta comme
je veux rester en ville car je veux
finir mes études et avoir un bon travail
ainsi je pourrais aider ma famille dans
le
[Musique]
futur si je pouvais devenir médecin j'en
serais très heureuse je resterai sur la
terre ferme et les mques pourrai venir
se faire soigner par
moi
les mokenes sont partis de Chine il y a
4000 ans ils ont survécu à tous les
dangers de la mer même le laboun le
terrible
tsunami aujourd'hui le mode de vie et
les connaissances millénaire des hommes
poissons sont en train de
disparaître il ne resterait plus que
2000 à 3000 moqu malgré tout ces nomades
des m ne sont pas préoccupés par le
futur d'ailleurs dans leur langue il
n'existe pas de mot pour
inquiétude on sait rien à propos de
l'avenir on ne fait que vivre ce qui se
passe ici
maintenant si quelque chose doit arriver
ça arrivera c'est
[Musique]
tout mais on veut rester sur la mer
danss
bateau c'est notre
vie
on veut continuer à manger du poisson
des fruits de
mer et se faire bercer par
l'eau c'est ce que souhait tous les
[Musique]
Moken j'aimerait aussi pouvoir vivre sur
un bateau avoir une
famille
je pourrais voyager et manger du poisson
toute ma
vie le peuple Moken est fait pour vivre
sur un bateau et voyager comme des
hommes
[Musique]
libres
au Cambodge dans ce village à quelques
kilomètres de Kong Cham plusieurs
familles Cham ont réussi à s'acheter un
petit
terrain et son clan font souvent escale
ici ailleurs les Cham ne sont pas
forcément les bienvenus ils perdent peu
à peu leur liberté de
mouvement à kampongcham on n pas ce
problème
là mais à pnomen on ne peut plus
accoster sur n'importe quelle
rive par exemple on ne peut plus se
mettre devant le Palais Royal et plein
d'autres endroits qui ont été
privatisés à peine on accoste sur ces
rives on se fait dégager
immédiatement et parfois on peut même
pas s'approcher des
berges
les Tam voient ainsi leur fragile
équilibre menacé et le fleuve est de
moins en moins généreux en
poisson
pour ce qui est de la pêche il y a une
grosse
différence avant on prenait 5 kg de
poisson par jour dans nos filets
maintenant on ne prend plus qu'un
kil
en fin de journée le couple rend visite
aux parents de sa
[Musique]
roche
nous aussi on était des pêcheurs on a
vécu de la pêche dès notre enfance on
vivait sur l'eau comme une fois marié on
a continué cette activité autrefis il y
avait beaucoup de poissons on pvait
gagner relativement bien notre vie avec
la pêche on a mis beaucoup de temps
avant d'acquérir notre maison sa roche
avait une dizaine d'années on a eu TR
enfants et on vivait tous ensemble sur
la
pirogue est t les de d'une fam pauvre on
n'avait pas d'argent pour avoir ne
serait-ce qu'un modeste petit commerce à
nous après notre mariage en complément
des emprunts que nous avons fait mes
parents nous ont aidé pour qu'on puisse
acheter une pirogue et pour avoir des
filets on a fait crédit auprès des
commerçants
chinois c'est vrai qu'il y a de la place
chez mes parents mais il n'y a pas de
travail j'aimerais changer de vie
quitter la pirogue et le fleuve mais
sans argent c'est
compliqué
à l'aube de la cinquantaine mot arpente
ce terrain qu'il rêve de pouvoir
s'acheter un endroit où sa femme et lui
pourront
[Musique]
vieillir j'aimerais posséder ce terrain
pour y construire une
maison à mon âge je ne pense pas que
j'aur un jour les moyens de l'acheter
travaillant le restant de ma
vie la pêche ne rapporte plus assez il y
a de moins en moins de poissons je ne
pourrait pas gagner assez
d'argent c'est la vie je fais avec mais
je serai aux anges si on m'offrait ce
terrain je serais vraiment
[Musique]
heureux
tout en continuant de rêver le couple
retourne à sa pirogue le petit n
flottant où ils s'aiment depuis 30 ans
et où ils ont conçu leurs si
enfants core et toujours le principal
alli un fleu majestueux qui les a vu
naître les accueille et les nourrit
depuis qu'ils sont au
monde on s'entend bien avec ma femme et
les enfants ne font pas de
problème donc je peux dire que je suis
heureux galère mais n pas grave on a la
force pour continuer
d'avancer
[Musique]
les tchames du Cambodge les mquenes de
la Thaïlande de peuples qui ont l'eau
comme pays et le bateau comme
foyer les derniers des nomades au mode
de vie d'un autre
[Musique]
temps
eh